you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news on today's program
the uk's chief negotiator to cop 26
admits the u.s and china can do more to
tackle the climate emergency we have the
exclusive interview
boris johnson and joe biden urged the
g20 to show leadership ahead of the
climate summit in glasgow
more than 70 people arrested in more
climate protests on the m25
and a 14 year old girl a city and a
country the finalists of prince
william's earthshot prize are announced
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world now and
we challenge those who are coming up
with the solutions now as we approach
the un climate summit in november
britain's main broker on climate is
turning the thumb screws on the u.s and
china the uk's chief negotiator two cop
26 was also pushed on our own gas and
oil exploration sky news is climate
change correspondent hannah thomas peter
spoke exclusively to archie young ahead
of that big summit in glasgow
china are hugely important there are a
quarter of global emissions but also the
steps that they can take to incentivize
their industrial industry to to really
ramp up and and deliver the electric
cars and and the the solar pv that the
world needs is huge
they have made serious commitments and
we know that they are serious about them
we were in china just recently and we
talked to them about what they plan to
do and we look forward to seeing clear
plans as to how they will meet their
commitments
does the uk's position on granting new
extraction licenses in the north sea and
continued extraction of fossil fuel
undermine its moral authority as we head
into cop26
i have
regular conversations with my
counterparts around the world where they
recognize the steps that we have taken
to keep this show on the road to bring
people together so there are always
challenges in terms of making sure that
every element of domestic policy is
aligned and pushing in the same
direction but i think actually our
global leadership is recognized the
international community is still well
short of the pledged hundred billion a
year
all of the reporting is that that's to
do with america not stepping up is that
the case from your point of view and
what can be done to change that this 100
billion goal was committed several years
ago and real progress has been made so
the last figures from 2018 showed that
we were at 78.9 billion a year
but let's be honest it's going to be
very hard for that to translate into 100
billion dollars a year by 2020. we are
pushing every single donor to deliver to
step up the uk we doubled our climate
finance so it's 11.6 billion pounds over
five years and we're expecting everybody
to do the same but america hasn't really
increased the amount that it's going to
pledge particularly for the size of its
economy what are you saying to your
counterparts at the u.s well they did
increase but we also know that they can
do more so we continue to to pressure
them to discuss with them what the
opportunities might be and we look
forward to hopefully some positive
signals in the weeks to come ahead of
cop26
and today the prime minister boris
johnson told the g20 to show the
leadership that the world needs to
tackle climate change he was speaking at
an economic and climate forum hosted by
the u.s president who called for global
action
without adequate commitments from every
nation in this room
the goal of limiting and warming to 1.5
degrees slips through our hands and
that's a disaster we have to bring to
glasgow our highest possible ambitions
those that have not yet done so time is
running now
meanwhile more than 70 people have been
arrested in climate protests on the m25
again today many of the demonstrators
described by the home secretary as
selfish had been released after blocking
the major motorway earlier this week
before then going on to cause more
disruption skies iva bennett has more
this was one of several locations the
demonstrators targeted this morning
either on or around the m25 here in
essex but also in kent and surrey also a
location near stanster airport on the
m11
the protesters tried to glue themselves
to the road blocking traffic on these
busy interchanges in one case also
pouring paint on the road trying to
cause disruption they're from a group
called insulate britain and they're
demanding the government does more to
make homes in britain more energy
efficient to do more to tackle climate
change it's the third time they've
demonstrated this week on the m25 what
was different this time around though
was the police response which was
noticeably swifter and also seemingly
more heavy-handed with the police
forcibly removing protesters from the
mood trying to from the road trying to
uh keep disruption to a minimum and that
followed comments from the home
secretary pretty patel
last night in which she branded their
protesters as selfish she said the
guerrilla tactics used by insulate
britain detract from their cause and i
know the public will agree that the
scenes on the m25 this week were
completely unacceptable the police have
our full support they must uphold the
law and take decisive action this kind
of disruption is dangerous and takes
police away from communities where they
are needed most so it seems the police
were following through on that warning
for their part the protesters have said
this kind of action won't stop until
their demands are met with some
demonstrators here today actually coming
straight from the custody center after
being released following their arrests
earlier in the week so if they're
prepared to do that i think this won't
be the last protest of this kind that we
see
well that's got a lot of people fired up
stay with us because we're going to be
discussing whether protests like the
ones we're seeing there on the m25 get
the message across today i'm joined by
the honorary president of the black
environment network judy linguang and
business greens editor-in-chief james
murray that's coming up for you in just
a few moments
meanwhile in some of the day's other
climate news now and greenpeace
activists have unfurled an advertisement
for a new climate chancellor nine days
ahead of those big elections in germany
it's a three-story ad and is asking for
the next chancellor to bring forward the
country's coal phase out and to ban new
petrol vehicles by 2025.
the current chancellor of course angela
merkel has faced criticism from
activists who say she shied away from
strong climate policies
a group of leading scientists have
written to the government demanding a
rethink of the uk's approach to hydrogen
they're asking for a more cautious
approach to blue hydrogen and an uptake
in green hydrogen it's called blue when
the co2 that would ordinarily be
released is captured and then stored
underground but scientists warned that
it uses more fossil fuel
firefighters in california have wrapped
the base of the world's largest tree in
a fire resistant blanket to protect it
from wildfires the tree which is named
general sherman is 84 meters high has a
circumference of 31 meters at ground
level i think they're going to need a
bigger blanket
now the sun may be shining today in many
parts of the uk but summer is now
unfortunately behind us winter is
approaching and it could be a rocky one
for energy bills almost everything that
could go wrong in energy markets has
gone wrong causing gas and electricity
prices to spike skies data and economics
editor ed conway explains why
one of the overarching kind of question
marks about how the uk's energy policy
is going to work in the future is what
do you do when the sun isn't shining and
the wind isn't blowing you know you're
reliant on wind turbines and solar
panels but they can be quite
intermittent well we're kind of learning
what's happening with that at the moment
because we don't have much wind right
now and at the same time we're seeing
something like this this this shows you
uh gas prices it's a future contract for
the future month uh going back a year
and just look at how much they've risen
in that period up by
450 to the highest level uh on record
there's all sorts of reasons for it and
partly it comes down to that the fact
that we're reliant more on it because
the wind isn't blowing as strongly but
you've also got less gas coming in from
russia you've got some
oil fields and gas fields which are shut
down for maintenance at the moment
you've got fewer stockpiles of gas right
now
but that is having a consequence right
now and we're seeing some companies
shutting down their production as a
result of that
and another thing that we have certainly
noticed recently is when you look at
electricity prices so specifically
electricity prices there was a fire in
an interconnector that brings some of
that electricity from france to the uk
uh just in just in the past week and
look at what that's done to electricity
prices
it really just reinforces the fact that
when we're talking about our energy
policy you can't just talk about
renewables you can't just talk about
wind turbines and solar you've got to
talk about what you do as a backup if
they're not bringing them much power
so as we're hearing from ed there
there's been changes to the uk energy
supply because of a number of factors we
want to bring in our data dashboard here
because it shows you the real time power
mix for electricity fossil fuels are
coming in at 53
at the moment renewables at 31 and
nuclear at 16 it's important to remember
though that that power mix will vary
according to the time of year and even
the time of day a national grid who we
spoke to today is keen for us to put
that into context
now prince william says that he launched
the earth shot prize so that he could
look his children in the eye knowing
that he had done his bit for climate
change the environmental prize
recognizes those who are coming up with
creative solutions to tackle the issue
and this year's finalists show that
there is no mission too big or indeed
too small when it comes to climate
action as sky's royal correspondent
rhiannon mills reports
a global prize designed to motivate and
inspire a new generation of thinkers
it's prince william's biggest ever
project the earthshot prize injecting
optimism into the climate debate
the ambition quality and range of
submissions has been amazing and should
fit us all with optimism and hope that
our goals for this decisive decade are
achievable
the 15 finalists include conservation
projects the city of milan and the
republic of costa rica and
groundbreaking tech innovation vinisha
umashanka from india is 14 and has
designed a solar powered ironing cart
in uk most of you are in at home right
with an electrical iron box
now here instead of ironing at home
most of us have to go to a shop like a
small stall where ironing vendors use
charcoal based iron boxes each of them
burn five kilos of charcoal every day
so that's 50 million kg of chocolate
every day in india alone knowing that
it's quite unsustainable i decided to
keep the same vibe and tradition but
make it more sustainable and modern that
it suits today's needs and our present
generation
william has been working with figures
like david attenborough convinced too
much pessimism was making people switch
off the five winners of the one million
pound prizes will be announced on the
17th of october the beginning of a
decade-long defining project for a
future king rhiannon mills sky news
hello again and welcome back to the
daily climate show here on sky news
we're getting straight into discussing
the climate issues of the day that's
with the honorary president of the black
environment network judy linguang and
business greens editor-in-chief james
murray good evening to you both good to
see you well we're going to start with
those protests on the m25 the country's
busiest motorway again blocked in
various places for the third time this
week by protesters a group called
insulate britain does this kind of
action make a difference or is it
counterproductive to their cause i
should say actually in the last hour
we've heard from the transport secretary
grant shaps who said that we all want to
live in a world that's cleaner but this
is counterproductive this winds up
motorists safety is put at risk and of
course traffic standing is the worst
thing for pollution so let's get
straight in there
judy what do you think and pretty patel
says these are selfish guerrilla
tacticians what do you reckon
well you know of course extinction
rebellion does inconvenience and upset
some people but extinction rebellion has
leaders are very clued up about the fact
that the design of a protest is about
getting media and therefore public
attention in order to get the message to
the highest number of people from my
experience once we will see the message
you know they then center on the message
what do you think about this james i
mean do you think extinction rebellion
have achieved their goals
well if their primary goal is to get
attention and get this uh issue in the
public eye and up the agenda then they
absolutely have by definition
i mean what i always think is most
interesting in some ways about these
protests is
that how inevitable they feel i mean if
you accept that we're in the in the
grips of a climate crisis that's getting
worse and worse and could have very very
grave repercussions for humanity as a
whole over the coming decades then it
was always the case that a group of
group within society was going to be
willing to take direct action to try and
resolve
that challenge and ensure that humanity
as a whole takes action and we've seen
that with all kind of justice movements
we saw that with suffrage we saw that
with the anti-slavery movement we saw
that with civil rights um and it just
stands to reason that there will be
groups who are willing to
break the law get arrested uh because
they in my view rightly see that we are
sleep walking towards a climate
catastrophe and they feel the need to
raise the alarm i mean there's kind of
there's kind of two debates here whether
you know whether the tactics are
effective and i think that is legitimate
debate uh but the idea that you know
that this these groups are going to go
away or the idea that these groups
aren't acting in good faith to try and
raise the alarm in the face of what
could prove to be an existential threat
um it just doesn't wash
and judy you could say that
inconveniencing the public is probably
the most effective way of getting
governments to respond i mean look what
happens when the train drivers go on
strike for example
absolutely i mean but if we move away
from the men of the protest for a moment
for me this time the real drama is in
the context of the simple message
insulate britain is a mundane almost
boring topic the real shock for me is
that this is the 21st century and we as
a rich country has not yet fully
insulated our social housing stock so
that poorer working people can afford to
keep themselves warm while we protect
the planet at the same time at this
critical time you know this sort of
climate justice dimension too has been
highlighted it's really important and
really close to my heart does it not
also show james that the um the climate
protests have evolved because extinction
rebellion had pretty broad aims it was
difficult to actually
pinpoint specific things that that they
wanted they just wanted everything to
change but this is so specific that they
could perhaps
make some change here do you think
i think absolutely i think one of the
legitimate critiques of extinction
rebellion from the off was that it was
too broad brush in some ways too
ambitious asking to get to net zero
emissions by 2030 is something that you
know isn't going to happen that that's
too big a lift but but what's
interesting about this is we are now
starting to see these more specific asks
and the idea of um having a national
program to insulate and improve the
energy efficiency of our building stock
i mean that's supported by the committee
on climate change that's supported by
the cbi that's supported by virtually
every think tank and green group going
that works in this space it's it's an
investment
that would deliver massive economic
benefits it would improve health it
would cut energy bills and it would cut
carbon emissions and it would help
resolve some of these um energy issues
you were just talking about with energy
price spikes because we'd be using less
energy in the first place so you know it
is a very um can he ask and it's
something that the government really
should be considering and prioritizing
if it wants to be taken seriously as a
global climate leader and you you never
you never um no we we might even get to
see the heat and building strategy
before cop 26 been long awaited hasn't
it well let's move on now to the search
for solutions we were hearing earlier in
the show about the earthshop prize it is
of course prince william's campaign to
find solutions and innovation to tackle
climate change from across the world
around half of those finalists announced
today were from the global south well
what does that say about our search for
solutions and judy there's a real
simplicity to some of these um
shortlisted uh solutions isn't there i
mean costa rica making micro payments to
people to just do their bit to protect a
little bit of rainforest
absolutely you know there are things
that only governments can do and that's
where all the protests and pressure
comes on but indeed there's some things
that individuals sections of society
like business and
ngos and so on can do and they do it
well because they're in touch with very
local characteristics and cultural
dimensions you know take the case of 14
year old phoenicia she notices that in
her country millions of people still use
street ironing services and she's
created a solar-powered ironing card in
a very sunny country to make a
difference it is amazing and you know
and i applaud prince william for saying
that he needs to be able to look his
children in the eye and say he did this
bit
you know as much as we live in a
science-dominated world it's still our
emotions and our commitment to family
that drives our strongest motivation to
act and to be fascinated inspired by
people that look like us
having amazing though it's important to
note though james isn't it that there
are no british short listies on that
list many of the ideas that were
shortlisted from from the global south
are we a bit arrogant in thinking that
it's g7 western nations that really have
the answers here
um i think there's a risk of that i
think there's a risk of in in every part
of the world is that countries see the
climate crisis and the sort of the clean
tech revolution that will hopefully help
resolve it as these kind of national
local regional issues but that's true
everywhere and and one of the most
exciting things about some of the
stories we cover at business green is
the huge breadth of of innovation and
investment that we're seeing in all
parts of the world including very much
in these emerging markets and in the
developing world i mean there's one of
these talking points you get a lot from
people who are opposed to climate action
you say well what about china what about
india what about these big polluting
countries that are you know are
investing in coal yes they are but
they're also in china's case the world's
biggest renewables market the world's
biggest electric vehicle market and we
are seeing um some catalyzing progress
uh from some of these countries that are
in some ways because they don't have the
legacy high carbon infrastructure
they're able to leapfrog that and deploy
clean technologies at scale at pace uh
ahead of some industrialized nation so
it's much more simplistic than the idea
that the industrialized world is going
to solve this on its own and then kind
of through its large s
help developing countries i think that
you know that is a borderline
neo-colonialist way to see it necessity
is often the mother of invention isn't
it it's been really good to talk to you
both tonight judy ling wong and james
murray thank you